[Music]
fish food chunky monkey these quirky
flavors are unmistakably ben jerry's but
what really sets the brand apart is its
activism despite being owned by one of
the largest food companies in the world
it's been really fascinating to see that
ben and jerry's has really held their
ground companies that take a stance on
social and political issues are becoming
more important to consumers according to
research by the polling firm ipsos 60 of
consumers said they would be more likely
to consider a brand that's aligned with
their own views so how does the company
blend activism into its business model
this is the economics of ben jerry's
ben and jerry's really takes a fairly
liberal stance on a lot of political
issues and ben and jerry's has not shied
away from making those positions very
public the company's social mission is
rooted in the values of its two founders
and their life experience having grown
up in the 1960s what's going on is
genocide ben cohen and jerry greenfield
founded the company in burlington
vermont in 1978. two years later they
were selling pints to grocery stores and
in the late 80s they began using their
ice cream to support social causes
they've spoken out about how they were
advised by counterparts in the industry
that speaking out and taking these
activist positions would hurt their
bottom line this was just not something
that
businesses were doing but ben jerry's
pushed ahead and by 1999 it reported 237
million dollars in sales
today the company says the overwhelming
majority of its sales comes from selling
packaged ice cream in supermarkets and
convenience stores what the company has
shown over the years is that if your
product is delicious is attractive you
know in other ways to consumers
you can do these things and still be a
successful business
thanks so much ben jerry's centered its
business on an idea it calls linked
prosperity which means that as the
company profits its community should too
so when ben and jerry's needed investors
to build its first manufacturing
facility in 1984 it offered stock
exclusively to vermont residents first
as a way to give back to the community
where it got its start
a year later the ben jerry's foundation
was born it received 7.5 percent of the
company's annual pre-tax profits to fund
community-oriented projects
in 2000 multinational food conglomerate
unilever bought ben jerry's for 326
million dollars but the ice cream maker
negotiated a deal where it could
maintain its own independent board of
directors
while unilever has made statements over
the years saying that these are not the
issues of the whole company
they have not been able to stop ben and
jerry's from making statements on social
media that get a lot of attention
because of how controversial they are
after the killing of george floyd in
2020 many companies started posting on
instagram to show their support for the
black lives matter movement while ben
and jerry's released this statement
saying we must dismantle white supremacy
they were so much more direct than other
companies and that's where ben jerry's
has continued to be different because
they've been doing this for decades they
have that credibility we need to have
people sitting in at their congress
people's offices at their senator's
offices and telling them we ain't
leaving till you pass a green new deal
but these bold statements haven't been
without backlash for example in 2021 ben
jerry's announced that it would stop
selling its products in jewish
settlements in the israeli-occupied west
bank and contested east jerusalem this
decision was criticized by jewish
communities around the
and everything world unilever produces
and by israeli politicians
two months later several state funds
sold or threatened to sell their
investments in unilever accusing the
company of breaking state laws that
prohibit the boycott of israel unilever
didn't respond to requests for comment
at the time the company declined to
discuss the divestments but reiterated
its commitment to israel
in february ben jerry's posted this
tweet criticizing president biden's
decision to send u.s troops to ukraine
unilever's ceo said ben and jerry's
needs to stay in their lane basically
and said that they should not speak out
about things that they're not experts in
a spokesman from ben and jerry said we
don't believe one must be a foreign
policy expert to promote the ideals of
peace and to oppose armed conflict as a
solution to solve problems
in addition to its public statements the
company's social justice initiatives are
also baked into every aspect of its
business model how the ice cream is made
how it's packaged and how it's served to
consumers
for example the brownies that are used
in flavors like half-baked come from a
bakery in new york that hires people who
face barriers to employment ben jerry's
also uses milk and cream from family
owned dairy farms and all of its flavors
are fair trade certified which
guarantees that farmers who grow vanilla
cocoa and coffee beans get a fair price
for their harvest
there's a flavor that's going to be
supporting
the poor people's campaign for special
edition flavors ben jerry's often works
with non-profit organizations a portion
of the proceeds will be
donated to be supporting the campaign so
it's a real
influence not just with consumers but
also by using their profits to give back
to these
mint
organizations
ben jerry's also has about 215
independently owned scoop shops across
the u.s
as corporate activism becomes more
important to consumers we might see more
companies voice their social and
political stances online so does this
mean it's the end of an era for ben and
jerry's
a spokesman from the company says ben
jerry's acts on values it cares about
but trying to go at it solo was never
the intention
you